- And the argument we had
recently, me and Lawrence,
was about oven gloves, ridiculous!
You know when you buy oven
gloves, you've got two options?
Like, I like to buy the two, individual,
separate oven gloves personally.
You know, one for each hand.
Their independent of each
other and you're free,
as you always imagined you would be
as an adult in your own kitchen.
(crowd laughing)
To move as you please.
He gets these oven gloves where
you've still got an oven
glove for each hand,
but they're joined together
by that filthy hammock.
(crowd laughing)
The most bacteria ridden bit
of fabric in your entire house.
It's a quilted germ blanket.
Oh, what you handling with that?
Please let it be food,
please say it's food
you're picking up with the germ cloth.
I can't wait to mange
whatever it is you're cooking.
(crowd laughing)
That's your full range
of movement with that.
(crowd laughing)
What is someone attacks you?
You can't defend yourself.
It could happen,
just 'cause you're getting
something out of the oven
doesn't mean the whole world stands still.
What are you gonna do, garrotte them
and hope in a weeks time
they get a fungal infection?
(crowd laughing)
They do not need to be joined together.
No ones threaded those oven gloves
through the sleeves of their jacket
like a pair of winter
mittens to my knowledge.
(crowd laughing)
Lawrence goes "They need to
be joined together, James,
"so they don't get separated,
thank you very much."
They're oven gloves.
They are oven gloves.
Correct me if I'm wrong, they
are not leaving the kitchen.
Neither one of them is
leaving the kitchen, are they?
There's an oven glove in the kitchen,
where's the other one?
Probably in the kitchen.
(crowd laughing)
Probably somewhere in the kitchen.
No one's leaving one
oven glove by the stove
then hitting the town, solo gloving it,
like a culinary Michael
Jackson going up to people.
You don't take that risk.
I said to him "Man, do yourself a favor,
"take that onesie oven
glove back to the shop.
"Buy yourself some proper oven gloves."
This is what he says.
He goes "Ah, oven
gloves, shcmoven gloves."
(crowd laughing)
That's how he argues
and he won, by the way.
(crowd laughing)
Oven gloves, schmoven gloves,
he's won every argument
we've ever had with that technique.
Oven gloves, schmoven
gloves, bowling, schmowling,
cinema, schminema.
(crowd laughing)
The only argument he didn't
win with that was one time
when we argued about schmoozing.
(crowd laughing)
If it already begins with a
schm, he ain't got nothing.
Believe you me, when
you're leaving the house
off to do a bit of schmoozing
and he's shouting schmoozing,
schmoozing after you
it's more encouraging than dismissive.
(crowd laughing)
Put a spring in my step.
Actually really good at schmoozing.
I thought I'd use this
opportunity in the show
to give you guys some schmoozing tips.
You look like some happening cats,
maybe you're gonna schmooze someone
at an office do, you know?
Now a lot of people tell
ya, when you're schmoozing,
have a good icebreaker.
At the top of the conversation,
break the ice, right?
What they won't tell ya, at
the end of the conversation,
un-break the ice, right?
You don't want anyone else sweeping in
taking advantages of all
the lovely little ice cubes
that you created, so freeze it
over again before you leave.
(crowd laughing)
Just as you're leaving just
slide something under the fence
like "death comes to us
all," something like that.
(crowd laughing)
Set the tone for the rest of the evening,
good luck anyone else
penetrating that fortress.
(crowd laughing)
Nod a lot, when they're talking,
you do a lot of nodding,
that lets them know that you're listening.
Every now and again just
throw in something like
"Wow, I don't normally nod this much."
Make them feel special.
(crowd laughing)